on sunny you got in incredible shape
so that your character would just be so
incredibly fit yes
uh and uh it has been it you got really
ripped we have a picture here
that went out there of you uh yeah
congratulations
uh i would like to know how to do that
if i don't have to change my diet or
exercise
yeah that's going to be a problem really
i mean there's certain things you can
inject into your body unfortunately
uh you also have to work out and change
your diet and do all sorts of different
things so
what do you do if you want to get that
kind of body and i'm not saying i do
but i if i were to get that kind of body
is there a person you can go to
sure well i why did you laugh
i'm an incredible uh athlete yeah
don't be fooled by my actual body
how did that distract you from my
athletic ability
uh no i i went to uh i went to the
trainer i i went straight to the trainer
of magic mike
i want to look like channing tatum in
magic mike so i went and i
i found the trainer and and i sat down
with him and i said okay look
i need to get into really good shape for
this show and uh
and i have an ideal male body that i
want to go for
and he goes don't tell me what it is and
i said why he goes
every dude for the last 20 years that
wants to get into shape
comes in and says the same thing i have
the ideal male body that
that i'm trying to achieve and i already
know what it is
and i said oh really what is it he goes
brad pitt fight club
yeah yeah and i was like god damn it
you're right it's bad yeah
was that that's the one you had in mind
right that's the one i had in mind
apparently one we all have in mind right
yeah so he said i just wanna um
i just wanna temper your expectation you
are not gonna look like brad pitt
in fight club no matter what we do
because i can get your body
close enough the problem is from the
neck up
you're not brad pitt and i was like what
about channing tatum he's like
sorry bud yeah yeah there's nothing you
can do i think it's
cruel for him to go to that like that's
implied you know
i i'd go i know what to do about the
face i'm not gonna yeah
well i have surgeons that are gonna do
that you know yeah i mean i i think he
was just
making sure that at the end of it i felt
like i got everything i wanted minus
brad pitt's face
do you have this issue now that you have
this body that's incredible and there's
an expectation that you have to maintain
it or you don't worry about that uh
no i don't i don't maintain it at all
right
no i uh i just went right back to living
normally
okay but there was a season of sunny
that i put on a tremendous amount i know
that was what was so
incredible is it your character on sunny
at one point i think you gained like 50
pounds or something
60. don't undermine my accomplishments
very few people say that you put on some
weight more than you think
very unusual 60 pounds 60 pounds how did
you do that
wait a minute i know how to do that yeah
i
figured out the secret to weight gain
good for you
don't tell it i i would the first 20
pounds was easy yeah
honestly the the the next 40 were tough
but i started
i started to i would have um my
assistant
in the morning go out and buy a pint not
a pint with a gallon of ice cream
and he would put it out on the counter
and i wouldn't eat it until
four o'clock in the afternoon because it
would melt and i would drink it
you would drink melted ice cream yeah
because you can drink that many calories
a day you can't eat that many calories
at least i can
right i actually love melted ice cream
have you ever i do that sometimes i wait
for it to get soft and then i drink
part of it i've never i never had that
much of it but now that you're
mentioning it it sounds absolutely
fantastic
okay okay i challenge you i challenge
you to something
drink a gallon of it every day for a
week
and tell me if you like ice cream after
that okay
okay my guess is i i think i know the
answer which is
yes i guess we'll see